[Musique]
five stars épisode 2 on reste à douc
avec on va parler d'un gros Babar euh
comme on aime bien un pivot blanc de nom
de Kyle
philippovski qui est aussi un sopomort
donc qui a décidé de faire une année
supplémentaire et pour se faire c'est
encore HUG et Manu qui m'accompagnent
pour vous faire le profil détaillé et
ciselé comme
d'habitude de ce joueur que l'on attend
quand même assez haut essayer de vous
dire aussi comment ça s'est passé la
saison dernière tout ça ça va être
présenté c'est maintenant on est parti
messieurs comment allez-vous bah écoute
ça va HUG toujours temps de de revoir du
du basket moche NCA
ouais moi ça va ça va très très bien
aussi kel philippovski pourquoi pas
partons dans les dans les dans les
grands mecs comme ça en espérant qu'il
fasse des des meilleures carrières que
que des lneur des choses comme ça alors
HUG j'ai maintenant du coup un petit peu
d'appréhension parce que tu t'es aussi
chargé de nous dire qui est cet homme et
après cette Masterc que tu nous as fait
sur ta rprctor j'avoue que que que je
j'essaie je m'attends à tout je me
prépare psychologiquement mais je crois
que même en étant préparé je serai
toujours surpris prê c'est à toi c'est
ton moment feu patate ah mais comme
disent les jeunes vous n'êtes pas prêt
pour cette mastercl de gros cquit j'ai
les termes j'ai les termes par pitié
ferme mon micro non mais je vous ai
préparé un 94 pieds avec HUG de Hal en
hommage à J Baas encore une fois ben tu
nous écoutes est pour toi celle-là vive
le Québec et donc je vais vous présenter
trois facts sur Ky philippovski il y en
a un seul de vrai et c'est pas évident
attention concentrez-vous bien parce que
c'est vraiment pas évident le premier
que j'ai c'est que Ky philippovski c'est
la série préférée c'est k XY ouais ouais
ouais ouais c'est attention parce que
celle-là elle peut être vraie elle peut
être vrai euh la deuxième que j'ai sur
kelle philippovski euh c'est qu'il a un
cousin qui s'appelle Philippe Lachot euh
d'ailleurs ça se voit dans le nom de
famille ça resté très très
proche oh punaise ouais et la la
dernière parce que peut-être que
celle-là elle est vraie peut-être
qu'elle est pas vraie euh c'est que
c'est un pivot euh sofomort qui joue
pour du qui fait donc SEP pieds donc on
est sur du 2 m 1 qui fait 104 kg qui est
né à New York euh où il a fait son son
lycée avant d'aller dans le Massachusets
qui était un des top euh lycée enfin top
des joueurs du lycée en sortant donc de
High School et qu'il était voilà noté 4e
5e dans une équipe de duuk avec
énormément de talent on avait parlé de
DK Lively maintenant NBA on avait parlé
de Ty spor dans un podcast précédent et
ce joueur-là a été euh attention
toujours dans un fact hein c'est
peut-être faux c'est peut-être faux tout
ce que je dis hein il a été élu euh
meilleur joueur euh du tournoi et il a
été élu rookie de l'année et puis pour
rester dans un fa toujours un fa
possiblement faux hein il a aussi un
frère jumeau qui joue à Harvard euh au
basketball il a des parents qui
joueraient aussi au basketball enfin qui
ont joué au basketball et il se serait
fait refaire pendant l'été des hanches
euh notamment il se serait fait abaisser
les hanches qui lui faisaient énormément
de douleur l'an dernier et euh ce serait
peut-être pour ça qu'il ne serait pas
allé à la draft cette année du coup il a
des hanches plus basses il est plus
explosif plus plus rapide plus puissant
il a pas de douleur voilà alors à votre
avis lequelle est vrai on va partir
surans la dernière même si la première
peut être vraie
hein Manu tu es d'accord la la trème
aussi oui parce qu'en faisant des
recherches j'ai appris que il sétait
fait faire refaire les hanches ou
tailler les hanches c'est shave the hip
je sais pas trop comment traduire ça
ouis ça sonne bizarre pour demand
chirurgien qu'il en est vraiment et tu
sa moi je le voyais bien avec un petit
un petit maillet là et qu' retaille le
truc au bord pour faire un truc ciselé
ça faisait très très peur quoi
franchement rich hips ça m'a ça m'a un
peu glacé le sang j'avais jamais vu ça
de ma vie mais ouais vous avez raison
les gars bravo vous avez été des fins
enquêteurs des fin Lim c'était bien la
troème qui était vrai donc bien joué
bien joué à tous donc Manu
ugladis c'est un saopomort donc il a
joué déjà l'année dernière avec du
qu'est-ce que ça donné en année 1 la M
année 1 c'est un un joueur qui a étit
euh titulaire au côté de de Lively où il
a piqué la place à Lively au au fur et à
mesure de de la saison et c'est un un
joueur qui touche beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup le
ballon il est un un taux d'usage de de
quasiment 30 % ce qui est juste fou et
en fait ce qui explique ça c'est son
rôle sur le terrain en en attaque ou
c'est un un mec qui qui fait du endof
qui fait du du posage de d'écran du
la de la passe highow du voilà il touche
la balle au poste il touche la balle à
trois points en fait c'est c'est
vraiment un espèce de point d'ancrage
dans dans la circulation de de balles
chez à à dou donc c'est c'est c'est ce
qui explique ça et et défensivement
c'est vraiment un un gars qui qui
s'occupe des grands par sa taille qui
est à 213 donc c'est un c'est assez
impressionnant de de le voir très très
grand et c'est c'est vraiment ça même si
ce qui est intéressant on en reviendra
peut-être plus tard c'est c'est sa
capacité à à pouvoir plus ou moins
switcher et et ne pas te ne pas perdre
le le duel face à face à du des joueurs
beaucoup plus petits des des meneur
notamment où il arrive à les plus ou
moins les cadrer et à bien gêner les les
tirs donc ça c'est c'est intéressant de
de voir ce rôle là qui l' quasi qui l'a
encore ils ont copié ils ont fait la
copie collée ils se sont dit ça va
fonctionner l'année dernière on va
recommencer et et et du coup c'est voilà
c'est le rôle qui
l'occupe cette année encore à voir si si
ce sera suffisant pour pour décrocher
une place en en loterie donc là tu m'as
parlé d'un joueur très polyvalent
capable un petit peu comme les pivots
modernes en NBA pas mal font savoir à
côté un peu organisateur de jeu créateur
de jeu même c'est vraiment ça son ticket
d'entrée pour la NBA pour pour moi ça va
être ça va être plusieurs choses ça va
être ça le le tir parce que c'est c'est
vraiment ça qui qui le rend spécial en
fait c'est quelqu'un qui apporte du
spacing en à son équipe donc c'est c'est
quand même assez intéressant notamment
NC où c'est c'est très très rare de de
voir des grands comme ça pouvoir bouger
à l'extérieur et et apporter du scoring
à l'intérieur mais c'est ce qui ce qui
va falloir qu'il donc c'est ça
parce que la la réussite n'est pas
dingue il a moins de 30 % l'année
dernière et cette année sur tris matchs
il a 24 % donc c'est voilà il sait le
faire mais faut améliorer un peu les
choses et et ça peut être ça peut
arriver parce que voilà le pour un grand
il fait 77 % sur les lancer franc donc
ça veut dire qu'il a quand même la
mécanique il a sa gestuelle qui qui est
là qui est présente donc il a les bases
de son tir donc c'est voilà va falloir
qu'il juste qu'il travaille quelques
quelques éléments avec son prochain
staff et là-dessus moi je suis assez
confiant et la l'autre chose sur
laquelle je capitalise chez lui c'est ce
qui est assez euh qu'on voit pas
forcément c'est son c'est sa passe son
sa vision je je le trouve vraiment un
peu sous côté là-dessus il il il arrive
de par sa taille à à avoir une vision en
fait du terrain qui est beaucoup plus
global et il arrive à trouver des des
vraiment des bonnes passes pour pour des
tirs ouverts que ce soit face sur le
côté euh ouvert avec lui ou sur le sur
le renversement et je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant il l'a montré notamment hier
soir contre kensas des des passes comme
ça où où il arrive à trouver ce ce
fameux renversement une main et j'espère
qu'il va capitaliser là-dessus parce que
ça ça peut le rendre vraiment vraiment
intéressant au au niveau supérieur ouais
HUG on achète ça aussi ou tuachètes
d'autres chos chez Kyle philippovski euh
bah globalement je suis asse d'accord
avec Manu le le tir alors par contre moi
j'ai des stats un peu différentes sur le
sur le tir j'ai un 37 % cette année
alors peut-être que ça prend pas en
compte certains matchs mais normalement
si euh je le trouve TR bien plus à
l'aise quand même cette année sur le sur
le pick and pop sur le l'attraper et
tirer en cas de chîn shoot ça s'explique
aussi peut-être par les par le justement
le fait d'avoir taillé les hanches là
parce qu'il disait l'an dernier qu'il
avait hyper mal que c'était très
douloureux de de plier de s'abaisser il
a été quand même dominant en attaque
peut-être que pour le tir ça peut ça
peut beaucoup jouer donc on va voir si
ça se confirme dans l'année c'est
philiipovski si tu le prends la draft
tuas tu as de l'attaque quasi
immédiatement il sait globalement tout
faire offensivement dans du scoring
euh pit and roll il s'est posé des bons
écrans et roulé il s'est slippé et
rouler il s'est joué au poste bas avec
capacité à finir des deux mains à
tourner sur les sur les deux épaules
donc à faire tomber beaucoup de faute
c'est vraiment un très très très très
bon attaquant et je suis d'accord avec
Manu aussi sur le sur la passe bonne
vision de jeu la balle elle colle pas au
main très fluide donc dans le moule
pivot très offensif euh
j'aime beaucoup quel était l'intérêt
selon vous pour lui de retourner une
année de plus en en en NCA parce que
c'était quand même un garçon qui était
quand même souvent annoncé au minimum
entre 20 et 30 LAN dernière dans dans
les dans les Mock Draft très souvent moi
ça m'a un peu étonné hein pour vous dire
la vérité qui qu' y a eu pas l'année
dernière qu'est-ce qui selon vous motivé
un peu ce choix et qu'est-ce que il
s'est dit je vais travailler pour être
sûr d' d'être pris au au premier tour
l'année prochaine en 2024 du coup je
sais pas si c'est un écran de fumé ou
pas mais je je regardais une interview
l'autre fois où il disait que justement
dès la marchemanes dès la fin enfin dès
l'élimination à la marche mes il avait
décidé de revenir donc il a il a même
pas attendu le les premiers retours des
ou tester sa côte en en nbet il pour lui
il avait décidé déjà de après c'est ce
qu'il dit est-ce que c'est un écran de
pas il il avait décidé de de se faire
opérer et de revenir ouais c'est ça
c'est que le mec il Ta il a fait une
opération qui l'a écarté du jeu pendant
6 mois
donc forcément si c'était prévu et qu'il
a normalement il aurait pas dû jouer l'
dernien jeer a dit il a assisté mais il
aurait pas dû jouer c'était trop
douloureux et on l' avait étéceillé de
le faire mais si tu sais que tu as 6
mois de récupération les vont pas
t'acheter te laisser passer donc c'était
un peu obligatoire et il revient et en
plus de ça Manu tu me tu me diras si tu
es d'accord ou pas c'est que l'an
dernier il a derric lively donc même
s'il a beaucoup joué pivot il a beaucoup
joué en fait en aide défensif dans des
rotations sur des sur en fait il lâchait
les quatre pour venir aider sous le
cercle alors que cette année il est
vraiment vrai pivot avec Marc Mitchell à
côté euh sur les séquences moins
d'entraîn de match et donc on peut le
voir défendre sur des pick and roll face
à des très grands quasiment tout le
match sauf qu'and a joyung sur le
terrain où il revient sur un rôle de
deuxème lame de deuxème rideau mais ça
aussi les franchises NBL vont vouloir
voir sur des mecs de sa taille parce que
a dominé sur beaucoup de mecs plus
petits que lui qu'est-ce qu'il peut
faire les deux côtés du terrain euh Manu
en prul disait que il était plutôt
intéressé justement par ce ce côté
défensif C cette capacité à à rester
devant même des joueurs plus petits et
donc censé être plus vif plus habile
est-ce que là les premiers matchs on est
un petit peu dans cette vibe là aussi
ouais c'est il arrive à à pas être
un point faible en fait c'est c'est ça
c'est c'est intéressant même sur des
joueurs qui sont quand même beaucoup qui
peuvent être beaucoup plus rapides que
lui sur sur les arr sur les lignes
arrières il arrive à à cadrer en fait
même si c'est même si ça sa pause
d'appui est assez assez limité je
reviendrai peut-être là-dessus après où
en fait il fait des petits pas mais
comme il est grand il a des plus grandes
jambes bah finalement il le travail de
corps qui suit fait fait fait la
différence mais mais ça aime vraiment
beaucoup après avoir sur des athlètes
décuplés qui sont plus forcément des des
joueurs NCA comment ça peut se traduire
moi il y a il y a un chiffre qui
m'étonne un petit peu par rapport à son
physique c'est son pourcentage de contre
que je trouve relativement faible il est
été l'année dernière à 2,6
ouais mais l'an dernière tu asevely
ouais forcément ça ça joue beaucoup
parce que l'autre c'est un pot gustique
qui met que des gifles tu vois c'est un
volur là cette année il est plus
responsabilisé euh après autant sur
l'extérieur je peux rejoindre Manu
j'aime bien sur la trappe l'orientation
et cetera autant pour le moment il est
tout mou c'est un oursemb en guimauve il
se fait enfoncer par la plupart des mecs
d'ailleurs on voit au rebond ça se voit
beaucoup dans le rebond il lui monent
tous dessus les les pivots advers dans
son dos ou bien ils vont lui mettre des
chocs il va reculer donc il a du bidou
ça aussi ça s'explique peut-être aussi
parce qu'il a pas eu de préparation
physique pendant tout l'été il va
falloir remettre en forme et la NV c'est
très très bien le faire donc on va pas
non plus se surinquiéter mais sur la
protectionction de cercle pur on va
quand même attendre d'un pivot et sur le
rebond ça peut être mis en défaut il
peut à peu rappeler un dans le jeu de la
comparaison tropative et on va lui
souhaiter ça à Nikola vutchevic tu vois
qui
euh qui au début était pas assez
physique et cetera qui est devenu un bon
rebondeur mais qui est pas non plus un
un protecteur de cercle mais qui va de
l'autre côté par ses touches de balle
par son spacing de te rendre te mettre
deux fois plus de points et donc tu vas
l'accepter je pense qu'il sera jamais un
protecteur de cercle de toute façon par
même s'il est grand il a pas il a il a
pas de verticalité pour pour répondre au
aux attaques adverses en fait donc pour
moi il le sera jamais un véritable
protecteur de cercle contreur Manu tu
nous as vanté sa qualité de passe est-ce
que c'est vraiment il a ce côté un petit
peu comme c'est un peu à la mode en NBA
de on recherche toujours on fait un peu
du c'est une copie cat League donc là
c'est c'est on est c'est un peu la
recherche du prochain yokish donc on
nous vend un peu Alper sengun et cetera
est-ce qu'on est dans cette même qualité
de passe que ces deux joueurs nommés ou
que il y a quand même on est un petit
peu sur un autre profil quand même
il y a quand même 600 profils d'écart
entre ces joueurs là ouais forcément non
philippovski c'est vraiment un un
passeur simple voilà si c'est pas
quelqu'un qui va pouvoir lancer un li
par exemple tu vois come on pe faire les
deux joueurs que tu viens de dire ça va
plus être moi si tu vois le comparer à
un grand passeur ça peut être à la
limite être un Joakim Noa qui était
vraiment un peu à l'avantgarde de ça de
de ce pivot passeur à
l'époque avoir 15 ans
maintenant ça peut être ça peut être ce
genre vraiment plus facilitateur
connecteur que que
véritable pasteur élite d'accord ça se
retrouve tu vois dans les les phases de
poste bas quand il est pris à de boum la
balle elle passe dans le corner ou dans
le cut ça se retrouve quand le mec vient
bien monter en défense sur le sur les
phases de end off et ben fin je vais je
pas rendre rible la rotation elle vient
et je ki c'est vraiment des phases
fonctionnelles très rapides du Quick
Play qui lit vraiment bien parce que là
moi dans ce que j'entends de ce que vous
me dites c'est que j'ai l'impression
qu'on a à faire vraiment un bon joueur
un joueur qui est capable de faire pas
mal de choses pour sa taille et son
gabarit qui a un bon bon IQ basket qui
reste cependant assez limité sur son
physique qui n'a pas de qualité vraiment
athlétique est-ce que ça c'est très
prochetable en NBA du coup h moi moi
j'ai j'ai j'ai un peu
peur moi j'yarrive pas à le projeter
comme ça parce que pour moi il y a trop
de trop de
je sais pas si je pense que le mot
lacune est un peu trop haut mais il y a
plein de petits points qui qui font que
pour moi il va pas il peut pas réussir
en fait notamment sur la la pose de pied
où c'est beaucoup trop sacadé le
mouvement est beaucoup trop est pas est
pas fluide donc est-ce que c'est les
hanches est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est ça je possible mais et du coup
pour moi ça c'est c'est vraiment
pénalisant parce que il va pas pouvoir
prendre les les les directions et et
garder justement ce ce contact avec des
joueurs beaucoup plus rapides et là que
ce soit même sur des quat où maintenant
des quatre fuillants on en voit beaucoup
qui sont capables de d'attaquer le
cercle c'est moi c'est vraiment ça qui
qui me fait peur c'est c'est vraiment
cette cette non capacité à à bien se
diriger au sol qui qui qui me fait peur
HUG dans les mêmees craintes aussi ou tu
as d'autres choses qui te viennent en
tête quand tu penses à Ky philipovski je
suis plus optimiste je pense parce que
l'apport offensif me paraît vraiment
vraiment trop important et je vois peu
de scénarios il va pas pouvoir être
efficace en attaque comme il tire qui
fait tomber des fautes et quiilibre bien
le jeu pour moi ça peut jouer le
problème qu'on peut qu'on puisse avoir
c'est que s'il est pas asse bon pour
être un pivot titulaire au bout de 3 ans
on parle pas d'un fres qui AR h on parle
d'un pivot voilà qui va se développer de
3 4 ans euh les pivots offensifs c'est
pas sur le banc c'est pas la norm NBA
quand tu es un pivot backup tu es un
tuas un éboueur tu vas faire du rimron
et tu vas donk donc s'il arrive pas à
s'imposer ça il fait pas il est capable
de faire du
RIM ça c'est ça il arrive pas à
s'imposer en en pivot offensif avec un
jeu qui va être assez lent et assez
centré quand même sur lui ce qui fait
beaucoup de S mais euh il peut très vite
disparaître par parce que son profil
n'est pas n'est juste pas assez moderne
là-dessus mais j'ai envie de croire que
une équipe va faire le Paris de se dire
ok j'ai un j'ai un fort B landler je
vais lui donner de l'espace et ben je
peux mettre kel philippovski à côté je
vais mettre des ailiers fort rebondeur
qui vont bien défendre et qui vont
mettre du catch and shoot et on va avoir
un spacing exceptionnel on va avoir des
lignes de Drive pour des arrières
explosifs vraiment fortes donc pour moi
il y a plein de contexte pour lequel ça
puisse marcher et je vais je vais juste
attendre de voir où il va tomber et j'ai
quand même
quand même assez d'espoir là-dessus euh
si vous étiez son agent qu'est-ce que
vous lui consz conseilleriez de
développer comme comme qualité corriger
ou améliorer une un point fort sur quel
point vous focaliserez vraiment HUG euh
de la muscu va falloir qu' bon ça lasfr
mais qui prenne qui prenne du coffre
dans le au niveau du des hanches du
bassin qu'il encasse un peu mieux le
contact et qu'il puisse au moins être un
pivot tu vois Tron comme les nurkit
comme les vchevic comme les trucs en HCH
que tu veux et et qui puisse être un
défenseur si ce n'est
moyen et puis à côté tir mais il va il
va tirer il va tirer donc ça va aller
euh Manu tu as autre chose à lui
proposer qu'un abonnement à basic feed
ou pas
ouais moi c'est un j'ai deux points sur
lesquels je lui dirais bosser c'est
c'est c'est qui s chète des des moves au
poste parce que là il y en a absolument
pas donc ça c'est compliqué il assez
intéressant sur face parce queil peut
driver un peu mais au au au poste enfin
postup d's au panier il est inexistant
il a pas la CAPAC il a pas ce footwork
en fait c'est j'en reviens à cette pause
de pied il a pas ce footwork là qui est
assez fluide pour pouvoir battre les
défenseurs grâce à ça du du coup il y a
ça et qui s'achète une caméra de recul
pour les les les écrans retard parce que
il arrive pas à prendre un seul rebond
même si en fait c'est assez trompeur par
rapport à ses chiffres il a des bons
chiffres au rebond il a plus de 8 cette
année je crois ouais dernière il devait
être pareil 8 9 mais c'est il a aucune
il a il a aucune technique de rebond en
fait c'est ça le sens du du saut il a il
quand il y a un adversaire en fait tu es
sûr qu'il va pas sauter et qui il va pas
il va perdre le B il va pas aller à la
bataille il s'en fiche un peu donc même
si c'est des joueurs des ailiers qui
sont plus petits que lui il il y va pas
en fait il a pas et je r viens à cette
verticalité il a pas cette verticalité
ce jump là pour pour aller chercher les
les rebonds donc c'est vraiment deux
points là qui qui moi me POS souci je
lui dirais bosse ça garçon c'est vrai
que sur le rebond tu vois que si c'est
un rebond long mais on en revient encore
à ces caslà les neworkit che Wev désolé
pour les pour les fans de de de ça mais
non mais c'est que dès que le rebond il
va être long ça sort de sa zone et donc
il peut pas le prendre quoi là on l'a vu
match hyper intéressant face à Arizona
il est défendu euh par Kishon Johnson
l'anciin de San Diego state des htech
big up au papa d'Allan eTTH qui lui fait
10 cm de moins mais qui va lui prendre
tous les rebonds et qui va lui mettre
des pouces dans le dos et du coup tous
les rebolons il les captent et pareil
pour ce que Manu disait sur le poste bas
moi je suis plus nuancé quand même mais
euh quand il est défendu par des mecs
plus petits il va être plus enfin mais
très costaud il va être très en galère
et ça c'est un manque de musculature
pour moi plus que de footwork et ouais
je rejoins bien sur le rebond aussi au
niveau du meilleur scénario possible
vous voyez dans quel genre de de profil
ça paraît pas évident comme ça moi quand
vous me le décrivez il y a il y a pas un
profil qui pop up comme ça dans mon
esprit mais je vous laisse être
imaginatif messieurs ouais bah je vais
rester sur les gar que je cite hein pour
moi le le scénario idéal c'est un
niikola vevic je mais il a ce côté un
peu comment pourra dire benger que qu'
c'est les joueurs en H que tu tu cites
ou pas ouais je pense qu'il a il y a un
potentiel de de de vraiment genre un mec
à à 20 points avec avec un gros volume
de tir extérieur et et puis fait tomber
les fautes donc ouais ouais franchement
c'est un un vrai ENF un vrai scénario
auquel je peux croire euh quand si je
suis plus nuancé c'est que tu vois il y
a pas de scénario euh offensif qui
réussit bien en NBA donc soit tu es un
tuas un top player enfin un top tu vois
genre un pivot titulaire fort comme les
gars que je cite soit tu disparais donc
faut faut faut y aller k bonne chance
Manu est-ce que il y a alors toujours
pareil hein comparaison n'est pas raison
mais est-ce queil y a un profil autre
qui pourrait te faire penser non j'ai
pas de j'arrive pas à j'ai envie d'être
méchant il dir zat tu vois
ou ah oui c'est méchant ah oui deè ça
j'ai pas de non j'ai pas de de
noms qui qui me viennent en tête comme
ça Bobby portis Robin Lopez tu as des
mec comme ça alors diffopez c'est c'est
c'est juste exceptionnel ce qu' fait au
rebond et au protection de cercle ouais
ouais bah Bob portis il est plus grand
il est plus grand moins mobile mais dans
le genre de de profil bon après il a
Yanis donc ça ça aide mais qui va donner
du spacing qui va faire tomber des
fautes euh pas un gros défenseur et qui
arrive à exister en nbillet ouais mais
il fait pas 6 pieds 7 pieds
ouais ouais mais bon il va pas tu vois
ce mec là sans vouloir faire un podcast
sur bortiste il va pas défendre il joue
pivot entre guillemets et il va pas non
plus bien défendre donc même sur des
petits switch pas
donc moi j'ai j'ai vous vous peut-être
que c'est complètement à côté de la
plaque je vais sans doute beaucoup moins
vu que vous messieur mais il y a un peu
une vaille dans la description de tout
ce que vous avez fait du du joueur un
petit peu à
la Luca Garza alors pas un peu dans le
côté pas très athlétique talentueux en
attaque mais qui aura du mal à exister
si euh juste offensivement un peu est-ce
que on n'est pas un peu là-dedans dans
le même dans dans les mêmes
problématiques Luca Gazza é un joueur NC
fantastique he c'est ça il y a aucun on
peut pas comparer les deux à ce
niveau-là mais dans dans le profil si on
les projette au niveau
supérieur ben pourtant Garza maintenant
il tire à trois points mais ça suffit
pas on va on va pas lui souhaiter hein
parce que Garza Garza il a pas eu de
chance enfin il a pas eu d'opportunité
non plus hein il est tellement
anachronique et pourtant il a développé
le tir extérieur il a maigri mais ce ce
serait quand même bien triste
hein on n pas parlé du côté
psychologique du garçon comment il est
sur le sur le terrain est-ce que ça a
l'air d'être quelqu'un facile à coacher
alors on sait que on a appris qu'il
avait des problèmes de de de santé qu'il
avait fait les efforts de ce côté-là euh
est-ce que c'est il y a des choses qui
justement sur le le fait de pas prendre
d'Herb bondes est-ce que il est il il
assume sa part de responsabilité ou il a
tendance à à dire aux copains queil
pourrait faire l'effort aussi moi je
vois pas bah encore c'est c'est c'est
difficile de de parler sur ces choses là
à l'écran ou c'est des choses qui qui
faut faut être dans la salle faut ouais
ouais
voir il a l'air assez assez impliqué
dans dans l'équipe dans ce qu'il fait tu
vois pareil sur du quand les quand il y
a des coups de sifflet le voilà il est
aussi dans la il les vocal il parle il a
pas il hésite pas sur les interviews que
j'ai pu regarder ou lire voilà il est
assez il parle bien il est ou je pense
qu'il en a dans la dans la tête donc je
suis pas j'ai pas vu de point de gros
points négatifs dans dans dans
l'attitude genre je baisse la tête des
points de stress ce genre de choses tu
vois il a un jumeau Harvard he ça peut
VO il est pas son jumeau mais ça peut
aider quand même en terme d'éducation tu
vois il a il a été suivi euh et puis
ouais c'est c'est un gentil garçon mais
c'est un peu trop un nounours autant en
attaque il te fait mal autant
défensivement tu tu lui rentres dedans
et il s'excuse quoi donc ça va falloir
va falloir développer HUG vu que tu as
la parole je vais te la laisser on
imagine comment dans son année 1 en tant
que rooky notre ami kel philippovski et
donc quel environnement idéal pour son
développement euh bah comme comme très
souvent sortie de Ban jouis pour moi
uniquement poste 5 euh on on lui
souhaite d'avoir des bons extérieurs
j'aimerais bien avoir des bons
extérieurs qui savent bien se lâcher
comme ça lui il va ouvrir des lignes de
passe et ces mecs-l ils vont les kiffer
tu vois les les drivers al je sais pas
qui on peut avoir dans dans ce dans ce
profil mais surtout en bas en bas de
tableau mais
ouais une une équipe qui va prendre du
temps pour lui et qui va pas essayer de
le faire courir comme un gros malade
parce qu'il pourra pas et euh faites
écarter le jeu donner du spacing et il
va il va briller question collégiale
pour finir question habituelle j'ai
envie de dire maintenant euh on y croit
comment euh en qualifiliipovski
en après je vais peut-être préciser de
ce qu'on entend par croire c'estàd
est-ce que on on pense que c'est un
joueur qui aura plusieurs contrat NBA ou
pas Manu moi je'y quoi très très peu
très très peu très réservé HUG
ouais je je vais être optimiste parce
qu'on a fait deux épisodes si on dit
vraiment qu'ils sont tous nuls des le de
c'est chaud hein parce que les gars il
va pas nous rester grand monde dans le
top 20 sinon on va être vite en galère
he mais non non je vais je vais y croire
je vais y croire et je vais l'acheter je
vais l'acheter dans le top 20 quand même
cette année messieur
merci beaucoup ainsi se finit l'épisode
2 sur k
philippovski un joueur qu'on suivra bien
évidemment tout au long de la saison
parce que c'est quand même un joueur
avec un potentiel offensif plus
qu'intéressant comme d'habitude nhésitez
pas à liker à partager à nous faire des
retours aussi on est toujours très
preneur de de vos avis et on vous dit à
très vite salut salut
messieur by
bye
[Musique]